mes chers
collègues la séance est ouverte donc
nous avons le plaisir d'accueillir ce
soir parmi nous Monsieur Philippe Lalot
qui est directeur du centre de crise et
de soutien du ministère de l'Europe et
des Affaires
étrangères le centre de crise qu'on
appelle le
CDCS et Monsieur Lalot va nous exposer
l'action de cette structure que nous
connaissons bien puisque nous avons reçu
le prédécesseur de de Monsieur alot et
nous avions analysé notamment les
opérations menées par le Centre au
Soudan dans des conditions qui étaient
assez assez
euh dangereuses difficile et même
tragique donc nous allons réfléchir à
l'action de cette structure depuis les
attentats du Hamas en Israël le 7
octobre dernier tant à l'égard de nos
ressor en Israël mais aussi dans les
territoires palestiniens on va pas qu'en
matière d'assistance humanitaire
d'urgenence notamment à destination des
populations civiles palestiniennes à
Gaza Monsieur l'Ambassadeur je vous
souhaite la bienvenue devant cette
commission vous venez de prendre vos
fonctions à la tête du
CD CS après avoir
représenter avec de façon extrêmement
brillante notre pays à Dakar j'avais eu
la chance
de d'être de faire un déplacement quand
vous étiez ambassadeur à Dakar et
j'avais pu euh vraiment apprécier la la
qualité euh de de la présence française
que vous incarniez dans ce splendide
pays
euh effectivement nous je devisais avec
le l'ambassadeur juste avant de venir
ici sur la
la situation à Dakar et la situation au
Sénégal qui est tout à fait intéressante
mais ce n'est pas l'objet de notre
discussion ce soir vous inaugurez donc
vos nouvelles missions dans des
circonstances particulièrement
difficiles je me posais la question de
savoir si il était bon quand on arrivait
dans un poste de d'arriver en plein
drame ce qui est une sorte de de baptême
extrêmement accéléré ou s'il
fallait il fallait il est préférable de
monter en puissance lentement en tout
cas on a pas le choix et vous êtes
arrivé en plein Dr mais je crois que
c'est au bout du compte euh mieux vous
avez un œil neuf vous avez des services
qui sont compétents vous avez une une
besoin de réactivité qui est très fort
et je crois que c'est c'est pas
inintéressant d'arriver dans ces dans
ces conditions
euh nous avions également euh alors le
CDS c'est un instrument majeur de
l'action du ministère de l'Europe et des
Affaires étrangères dans la crise
actuelle puisqu'il est chargé de la
veille de l'anticipation de l'alerte et
de la gestion des crises se déroulantes
à l'étranger et nécessitant soit une
réaction un événement menaçant la
sécurité des ressortissants français
soit une action humanitaire d'urgence on
peut dire que là nous sommes servis les
critères sont réunis actuellement au
Proche Orient alors à l'occasion de
l'examin des crédits de la situation
action extérieure de l'État notre
rapporteur pour avis qui était monsieur
clinger qui n'est pas ici maintenant
mais adresser le bilan vous inquiétez
pas il y a pas énormément de monde mais
après ils écoutent tous si c'est
enregistré ils regardent tout ça dans
leur bureau avec avec beaucoup de
beaucoup d'intérêt monsieur clinger
avait dresser le bilan de l'action du CD
du CDCS dans les crises de ces dernières
années il n'est pas ici question de se
livrer à nouveau à cet exercice vous
arrivez en plus ça serait ce serait
absurde de vous le demander mais plutôt
d'informer cette commission sur les
différentes actions que vous avez
accompllies ces dernières semaines pour
le compte du ministère en vue des deux
objectifs que j'ai évoqué tout à l'heure
le premier de ces objectifs c'était donc
de rapatrier nos compatriotes en France
au lendemain des attentats du 7 octobre
plus plusieurs avions spéciaux ont été
affraités au départ de Tel Aviv et nous
souhaitions savoir nous souhaitons
savoir précisément combien de Français
ont pu en
bénéficier et dans quelles conditions
dans les territoires palestiniens ont
recensait un peu plus d'une cinquantaine
de ressortissants me semble-t-il si mes
informations sont exactes et d'une
centaine d'ayant droit certains employés
d'ONG humanitaires ont pu sortir par la
porte de Rafa grâce à l'Égypte et
j'imagine que vous pourrez nous faire
aussi le point sur cette question ainsi
que sur le sort des autres qui sont
éventuellement toujours sur place là
nous sommes effectivement extrêmement
extrêmement soucieux d'avoir une
information aussi précise que possible
dans la mesure où vous-même vous en
disposez le deuxème de ces objectifs est
l'acheminement de l'aide humanitaire
aussi bien pour Israël dans un premier
temps que pour les les populations
palestiniennes à Gaza et peut-être dans
les camps de palestin dans les camps de
Palestiniens de la région sur une durée
plus
longue dès les premiers jours de la
crise sur décision du Président de la
République la France a déclenché un plan
d'urgence pour venir en aide aux civils
de Gaza quelques 20 millions d'euros si
je je suis bien informé ont été
débloqués plusieurs avions de transport
hum humanitaire ont acheminé des
fournitures humanitaires et deux navires
militaires dotés d'équipement
hospitaliers le tonner et le dixmud ont
été dépêchés sur zone sans doute
pourrez-vous nous apporter des
précisions à à cette égard sur la façon
dont il procède et ce qu'ils réussissent
à faire et ce qu'il ne réussissent pas
éventuellement à faire parce que c'est
pas facile d'intervenir sur un terrain
de cet ordre pour le plus long terme la
conférence human ire qui s'est réuni à
Paris à l'initiative du Président de la
République le 9 novembre dernier a
permis d'enregistrer près de 1 milliards
d'euros de promesse d'IDE ça c'est
toujours les promesses d'aide c'est
c'est très très élevé au moment des
conférences ça tend ça une certaine
difficulté parfois à se manifester
concrètement espérons désormais que ces
conditions permettront rapidement de
concrétiser l'assistance aux civils
j'imagine par ailleurs que le CD CS est
associé plus ou moins à la gestion de la
très délicate question du suivi de nos
ressortissants qui sont ou peuvent être
des des otages du Hamas au sein de la
bande de Gaza ça sans dévoiler de
quelconques informations confidentielles
sommes très conscients
que vous devez appliquer dans ce domaine
la fameuse formule que de Henry
Kissinger quand on lui demandait un
journaliste lui avait demandé quel était
quand il était secrétaire d'État quelle
était la disposition des forces
nucléaires tactiques en Allemagne il
avait eu cette réponse que j'apprécie
beaucoup I could tell you if I didn't
know je pourrais vous le dire si je ne
le savais pas et
effectivement je crois que plus vous
savez de choses moins vous pouvez en
dire parce que ce sont des matières
extrêmement délicates qui impliqu le
recours à des intermédiaires qui
implique toute une gestion qui ne peut
être efficace qu'à la condition d'être
relativement même plus que relativement
absolument discrète mais enfin peut-être
pourriez-vous nous nous dire quelques
mots sur ce que sur ce que vous sentez
ce que vous savez
comme possible comme
population possible en otage nous sommes
quand même très très touché par le fait
que notre pays a a perdu si je 41 de ses
membres jusqu' comment 40 av on m'a dit
qu'il y en avait un de plus depuis on
m'avait dit dimanche 40 40 40
ressortissants français c'est quand même
quelque chose de très grave et dans la
mesure où vous pouvez nous nous éclairer
un peu sur les otage nous vous
écouterons mais nous comprenons très
bien que vous soyez astreint à une très
grande discrétion alors Monsieur le
Directeur si nous souhaitons fortement
disposer de davantage de précision sur
l'action de la France par votre
intermédiaire nous apprécierions
également que vous la restituiez dans un
contexte plus global vous êes quand même
un grand
ambassadeur global et comparatif avec
les autres États qui interviennent qui
soi nos partenair direct ou non ainsi
qu'avec les principaux acteurs non
gouvernementaux du champ humanitaire
nous
sommes nous voyons à l'action et nous
voudrions effectivement nous comparer en
espérant que la comparaison nous
permettra de ne pas nous désoler euh
beaucoup de dirigeants à commencé par le
président Biden ont souhaitit mettre
l'accent sur l'aide à fournir aux
populations civiles de Gaza vous devez
avoir une certaine idée de l'effort
que leur pays fournissent concrètement
et nous sommes intéressés par ces
éléments qui constituent un marqueur de
l'engagement de la communauté
internationale dans cette crise et nous
voudrions effectivement savoir si ce que
nous faisons les uns et les autres autes
tous ensemble et de près ou de loin à la
mesure
de d'une partie au moins des besoins
constatés de même en votre qualité de
diplomate chevrené il ne vous est pas
interdit je le disais à l'instant
d'avoir une analyse du déroulement des
événements et de nous la faire partager
pour connaître l'intérêt de vos
raisonnements je suis sûr qu'ils
intéresseront au plus haut point cette
commission voilà monsieur que
l'ambassadeur
euh
la le champ dans la dans lequel nous
serions heureux que vous interveniez je
vous laisse maintenant la parole alors
nos usages
sont que vous fassiez une introduction
qui est entre 10 et 20 minutes comme
vous comme vous le souhaitz si ça
déborde un peu ça n'est pas grave mais
une une introduction substantielle
ensuite les représentants des groupes
euh groupe par groupe vous pose une
question en 2 minutes et demi à laquelle
vous vous vous essayez de répondre en 2
minutes et demi sachant que je n'ai
aucun moyen de CO sur vous et que les
moyens de CO que j'ai sur mes collègues
bah c'est pas facile facile non plus et
après quand les groupes se seront
exprimer enfin euh des parlementaires à
titre individuel auront l'occasion de
vous poser une question cette fois-ci en
une minute et là vous on essaie de
répondre en une minute on est dans le
dans l'échange dans l'échange
extrêmement bref mais et puis à la fin
vous concluez dans si il y a des choses
que vous auriez eu envie de dire et vous
n'avez pas eu l'occasion de dire vous
concluer comme comme il vous plaira
voilà le le schéma que je vous propose
en vous renouvelant mes remerciements
pour votre disponibilité et comme vous
imaginez bien euh nous sommes ici
extraordinairement intéressé par ce que
vous allez dire car nous mesurons tout à
fait tous je crois dans tous les groupes
l'extrême gravité de la situation que
nous traversons je vous
remercie merci monsieur le Président
merci pour vos mots très élogieux mon
égard et je dois avouer que je dois
avouer que je vous retrouve avec un un
grand plaisir après en effet cette
escapade que vous aviez faite euh au
Sénégal il y a de ça quelques mois et
qui avait été très utile euh pour dire
le moins à la relation bilatérale avec
ce grand pays partenaire qui est le qui
est le Sénégal euh monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les les députés
mesdames et messieurs je veux tout
d'abord vous remercier de l'intérêt que
vous portez au centre de crise et de
soutien et et et à son action et puis
vous remercier de me donner
l'opportunité ce soir euh de vous
détailler un peu euh ce que fait le
centre et de manière générale mais plus
particulièrement dans le contexte de
crise particulièrement aigu que
connaissent Israël et la bande de Gaza
depuis le 7 octobre dernier euh le
centre de crise est une espèce
d'urgentiste euh
euh de l'action
internationale de la France il
fonctionne 24h sur 24 7 jours sur 7
c'est vrai en régime de croisière toute
l'année et c'est plus particulièrement
vrai quand se produisent des crises à
travers le monde de quelqu crise
d'ailleurs qu'il s'agisse de nature
sécuritaire ou lié à des catastrophes
naturelles alors que nous devvisions
pour reprendre vos termes monsieur le
Président avant d'entrer dans cette
salle euh je vous disais que j'avais en
effet pris mes fonctions il y a un peu
moins de 3 mois et que nous avions
enchaîné avec mon équipe eu des crises
au Gabon au Maroc en Libye au au haut
cararabak et maintenant en Israël en
Palestine C crises en un peu plus de 2
mois et je vous disais également que ce
qui était remarquable c'est non
seulement la fréquence des crises mais
le fait qu'elle elle elle elle gagne si
je pu dire en gravitéité chaque fois à
chaque fois ce qui nous fait regarder
l'avenir avec une certaine préoccupation
on va dire ça comme ça et donc le centre
de crise est mobilisé toute l'année mais
il est mobilisé plus particulièrement en
en en période de crise et il estest
depuis depuis le le 7 octobre il est
parce qu'il faut faire preuve d'humilité
euh bien évidemment avec tout notre
réseau diplomatique et consulaire et en
particulier pour ce qui concerne cette
crise n nos consulats généraux à
Jérusalem à téaviv et auoker en
particulier et nos ambassades dans dans
la région puisque cette crise a aussi
une dimension régionale vous le savez
vous l'avez rappelé monsieur le
Président le centre de crise a deux
missions principales la première c'est
euh d'assurer la sécurité des
ressortissant français à l'étranger euh
et la seconde c'est d'intervenir dans
les situations d'urgenence humanitaire
je vous disais également qu'il avait
cette particularité comparé euh euh à
d'autres structures euh euh à l'étranger
puisque vous mavez invité à faire un peu
de parangonnage pour parler comme
Académie française euh je n'ai pas en
fait de de de d'équivalent puisque à
l'étranger la plupart du temps on sépare
euh la gestion de crise euh de la
humanitaire et je trouve que le modèle
français de ce point de vue est assez
intéressant et je trouve plutôt
pertinent je le dis avec beaucoup de
décontraction parce que je j'arrive
parce qu'il permet de gérer la crise
dans la durée c'est-à-dire de la
préparation à la crise on pourra y
revenir si vous le souhaitez notamment
les plans de sécurité de nos ambassades
les points de rassemblement les tout
tous les la planification d'éventuelles
évacuation la crise dans ce CASL de plus
aigu je vais revenir au cas particulier
dans la bande de Gaza et puis la sortie
de crise également et donc cette espèce
de continuum comme on dit est en soi
quelque chose qui est intéressant parce
qu'il a une certaine il a une certaine
cohérence donc ces deux mandats ou ce
mandat double ces deux missions je vais
revenir
successivement à l'instant je je je
précise simplement que bien évidemment
cette action du du du CDCS s'inscrit
dans un paysage plus général une
approche plus générale telle qu'elle a
été défin au cas particulier par le
président de de la République euh
puisqu'elle est cette approche vis-à-vis
de de ce conflit euh euh
entre Israël et et et Gaza euh elle
présente trois dimensions au moins une
dimension humanitaire je vais y revenir
euh qui qui recouvre d'ailleurs
plusieurs sujets chacun très complexes
euh la question du respect du droit
international humanitaire la question de
la protection des personnels des civils
et des personnels humanitaires la
question des accès euh pour répondre aux
besoins immense des populations à Gaza
notamment donc une dimension humanitaire
une dimension sécuritaire également qui
est une dimension qui recouvre à la fois
des sujets liés à la lutte contre le
terrorisme en général le Hamas en
particulier de manière générale tout ce
que nous pouvons mettre en place nous et
en coordination bien évidemment avec nos
grands partenaires pour éviter un
embrasement régional à la suite de cette
crise ou en parallèle de cette crise euh
deuxièmement et puis troisièmement des
aspects plus
politique c'est-à-dire l'idée selon
laquelle sans horizon politique on peut
pas
espérer trouver une isue durable à cette
crise et à ce conflit c'est toute l'idée
en effet de relance du processus
politique avec les Palestiniens et
notamment cette solution et je n'en
connais pas d'autres des deux états pour
reprendre la formule aujourd'hui bien
connu vivant côte à côte en paix et en
sécurité donc il y a ces trois piliers
là qui forment en fait euh une espèce de
de d'arrière-plan dans lequel s'insère
l'action pour le coup très
opérationnelle du Centre de Crise euh
nous n'avons pas de fonction d'ordre
doctrinal ou pour définir des des
positions qui seraient très politiques
ou sur les principes mon équipe
c'est-à-dire quand même 110 personnes 45
personnes 110 personnes 11 personnes 110
personnes travaill sur des sujets très
concret à mettre en œuvre des des des
des projets des initiatives qui sont
très euh très pra
je vais baler rapidement les les deux
volets donc pour le dire rapidement
consulaire et
humanitaire au titre des aspects
consulaires en distinguant ce que le
centre a
fait pour nos ressortissants en Israël
d'une part et puis d'autre part ce que
le centre a fait et et continue à faire
bien sûr pour nos ressortissants et les
agents du ministère des Affaires
étrangères dans la bande dans la bande
de
Gaza si je regarde déjà ce qui s'est
fait euh euh avec la Communauté
française en Israël euh je dois dire euh
en introduction et puis pour reprendre
une une remarque que vous avez fait que
on déploore aujourd'hui euh 40 victimes
françaises euh dans les attaques
terroristes du du du 7 octobre et et
leur suite immédiate c'est un très lourd
bilan et c'est un bilan qui n'est pas
définitif euh c'estàdire que on peut
encore euh euh euh av voir à compter
comptabiliser des des victimes des morts
des morts supplémentaires euh nous avons
bien évidemment présenté nos
condoléances aux familles je réitère ici
c'est ces condoléances de la manière la
plus solennelle nous sommes en contact
avec les familles de chacune de ces
victimes euh pour voir l'aide que nous
pouvons leur apporter elle elle est de
différentes natures depuis une aide
médicau psychologique de soutien
psychologique
jusqu'à des aides de nature plus plus
plus juridique d'accès à un certain
nombre de fonds qui peuvent apporter un
soutien y compris un
soutien un soutien
financier 40 victimes donc à date
de nos compatriotes sont portés disparus
et nous utilisons ce terme
disparu et non pas celui d'otage même
si nous savons qu'un certain nombre
d'entre eux sont retenus en otage dans
la bande de Gaza par le Hamas ou
d'autres groupes terroristes mais nous
n'avons pas la la
certitude que l'ensemble des h
leçons nous mettons tout en œufre pour
bien évidemment et ça a été dit et par
le Président de la République et par la
ministre Catherine Colona tout en off
pour obtenir leur leur
libération comme vous l'avez annoncé je
n'en dirai pas plus ici dans dans ce
format là tout simplement parce que
l'une des conditions de la réussite pour
obtenir la libération de nos
compatriotes c'est précisément de d'être
le plus discret possible et d'observer
la plus grande confidentialité sachez
que nous utilisons tous les canaux à
notre euh disposition pour pour obtenir
leur leur retour dans le au sein de leur
au sein de leur
famille excusez-moi quand vous dites
nous avons perdu nous Français 40 de nos
compatriotes nous avons personnes
disparu
euh nous avons rapatrié euh un certain
nombre de gens est-ce que vous avez le
sentiment d'avoir les moyens d'un
recensement complet exhaustif de la
population française qui a été affectée
par le 7 octobre complet oui exhaustif
peut-être
pas oui non c'est c'est c'est je vous
dis ça parce
que il se trouve que et c'est pas le cas
simplement dans cette crise là on voit
parfois se manifester au fur et à mesure
du déroulement de la crise des
ressortissants qu'on avait pas recensé
et et par ailleurs élément de complexité
supplémentaire dans le cas particulier
nous cherchons je vais
revenir nous avons cherché à nous
occuper non seulement de nos
ressortissants donc qui ont la
nationalité française mais aussi de
leurs aillant droit qui ne l'ont pas
nécessairement et on a étendu le champ
de de notre action à nos employés nos
agents de l'Institut français de Gaza
qui sont Palestiniens mais dont nous
avons estimé s'agissant d'agents qui
pour certains d'entre eux travailler
pour depuis plus de 20 ans pour nous que
nous leur devions cela ça n'était pas
une obligation au sens juridique du
terme euh n nous ne leur devions pas au
sens juridique protection consulaire
comme nous le devons à à nos
ressortissants au ressortissant français
en revanche c'était une obligation que
nous avons jugé d'ordre d'ordre moral
mais je vais revenir peut-être si sur
sur ce sujet parce que c'est un c'est un
sujet intéressant qui trouve d'ailleurs
son intérêt pas simplement dans cette
dans cette crise
eu pour finir d'un mot sur sur ces
otages ou ces ces
compatriotes disparus je rappelle
simplement que le Président de la
République encore tout récemment le 9
novembre a appelé au moment de la
conférence humanitaire à laquelle vous
faisiez référence monsieur le Président
à la Libération je cite immédiate et
sans conditions des 239 otages parce
qu'il se trouve trouve que nous avons h
de nos compatriotes qui sont porté
disparu mais que c'est le cas de
beaucoup d'autres pays et de pays
partenaires très très
proches le centre a activé une cellule
de crise dès le lendemain des attaques
donc dès le dès le 8 octobre et donc a
commencé ce ce
fonctionnement en 38 c'est comme ça
véritablement que ça se passe
l'intensité de la crise était telle que
nous avons dû solliciter non seulement
les agents du CDSS qui tout tout fait
normal c'est leur métier mais aussi le
vivier qui est constitué et formé au
sein même du
ministère et puis même au-delà au vivier
qui est constitué au sein de la
Croix-Rouge puisque nous sommes liés à
la Croix-Rouge par une convention de
partenariat qui nous permet d'accueillir
en notre sein quand une crise dépasse un
certain seuil d'ampleur un certain
nombre de bénévoles notamment pour
armer la réponse téléphonique eu juste
pour vous donner une une idée euh
lorsque vous travaillez comme ça en 3 x
8 vous avez besoin de
euh de d'une trentaine de personnes par
Shift et donc vous consommez euh 100
agents par jour euh alors certains
reviennent bien évidemment d'une journée
sur l'autre mais donc c'est c'est ça ça
demande beaucoup beaucoup de de moyens
de ressources de de de
euh de dévouement aussi des des
personnels que que que pour certains
rien n'oblige à venir servir comme ça le
jour et la nuit dans tous les cas ça a
permis je
pense à tous les Français qui le
souhaitaent de passage au résidents en
Israël de pouvoir entrer en contact soit
directement avec le centre de crise à
Paris soit avec notre réseau
diplomatique et consulaire sur place à
commencé par nos deux consulat généraux
de de té Aviv et de de
Jérusalem chacune de ces personnes a été
ensuite recontacté
individuellement pour savoir très
précisément si elle
souhaitait bénéficier des vols qui
allaient être mis en place ou qui était
mis en place ou si au contraire elles
estimaient pouvoir ou souhaitait rester
sur place en Israël au total ce sont
5000 appels que la cellule de crise a
traité et
4000 courriels et entre le 12 et le 18
octobre nous avons organisé 15 vols
spéciaux à destination de de telav vive
qui ont permis puisque vous me posiez la
question de votre propos liminire
monsieur le Président de ramener en
France
3500 français et ayant droit eu nous
avons déployé deux agents du CDCS au
sein de notre consulat général pour
aider à l'accueil dans les aéroports
c'est des gens qui sont très habitués à
faire des manifestes à à remplir des
avions en fait de façon à ce qu'il a pas
de place perdue et de la même manière
pour la première fois je crois nous
avons isé en tous les cas avec cette
ampleur là ce qu'on appelle la Task
Force sanitaire internationale
c'est-à-dire le vivier qui est constitué
à partir de personnel médicaux et
paramédicaux dans nos hôpitaux et qui
sont déployables à l'étranger en période
de crise ce qui a permis d'assurer une
présence d'un médecin et d'un
infirmier sur chacun des 15 vols de
façon à prendre soin de de nos
ressortissants entre leur départ de
TelAviv et jusqu'à le arrivée en France
à rissie ou à à Orli c'est c'est C 3500
ils étaient c'était des gens qui étaient
basés tous à Gaza en cjordanie
quelquesuns en Israël là je ne traite
qu'Israël is d'accord je vais venir sur
la la bande de Gaza ensuite euh et
d'ailleurs nous n'avons arrêté les vols
spéciaux euh que lorsque nous avons
estimé que
euh nous n'avions plus enfin nos
ressortissons qui pouvait avoir euh euh
qui pouvait qui pouvait souhaiter
rentrer non pas immédiatement que là
qu'on les aurait pris mais une semaine
plus tard ou 15 jours plus tard estimer
devoir rentrer ceuxa de nos
ressortissant pouvaient euh utiliser les
lignes commerciales classiques qui
continuent à fonctionner entre Paris et
telavive notamment euh via la un certain
nombre de de de compagnie soit soit
régulière soit soit lowcost quand vous
avez fait ça il n'y avait que des les
les les parce que les vols commerciaux
étaient interrompus en fait alors pas
tous euh mais il n'y avait plus
suffisamment de vols commerciaux pour
répondre à la demande
et donc pour éviter d'avoir ce qui
c'était ce qui risquait de se produire
des fils interminables de gens qui
auraient été placés sur des liste
d'attente et qui n'aurait pas pu partir
avant 15 jours ou ou plus c'est à ce
moment-là qu'on a décidé de mettre en
placeeses ces vols euh jusqu'au moment
où encore une fois on a estimé que on
pouvait on pouvait les arrêter
euh je voulais saluer devant vous parce
que je pense que c'est important euh et
c'est vrai dans toutes les opérations
d'évacuation me dit-on
euh veation rapatriment l'ensemble de de
nos collègues qui se mobilisent pour
organiser le dispositif d'accueil aux
aéroport c'est vrai de de la
préfecture sur place la préfecture
déléguée à la sécurité la sûreté des des
plateformes aéroportuaires qui s'agisse
de de celle de roissie ou de celle
d'orli c'est vrai de la Croix Rouge
également que j'ai cité c'est vrai du
SAMU et c'est vrai aussi de
l'association France horizon euh avec
laquelle on a là aussi une convention de
partenariat et qui assure je vais
revenir à la fois des des des soutiens
médico-psychologiques de gens qui
peuvent être assez traumatisés de ce
qu'ils vivent sur le moment et puis
parfois dans le plus long terme d'une
part et puis d'autre part c'est la même
association qui avec nous organise des
hébergements d'urgence pour ceux qui une
fois arrivés à Paris n'ont pas de quoi
se loger au moins le temps qu'il qu'il
puisse se retourner sont des dispositifs
assez lourds he pour pour l'avoir vu
fonctionner et pour les retours d'Israël
et pour les retours de Gaza et à Orly et
et à rissi et je veux dire ce sont des
des gens c'est admirable et je voulais
ici le leur leur rendre cette cet
hommage ça c'était pour je risque d'être
un peu long ça c'était pour je vais
accélérer ça c'était pour Israël pour
Gaza
euh alors déjà on on déplore la mort de
deux enfants vous en avez certainement
entendu parler commencé par par la
presse et pour ce qui concerne notre
assistance consulaire euh elle a consité
dans un premier temps a essayer de
recenser
euh nos ressortissants leurs ayant droit
nos employés et leurs familles
euh ce qui a permis en effet euh de pass
enfin ce qui a permis en effet ce qui ce
qui ce qui ce qui s'est fait en deux
temps dans un premier temps on a isolé
les 54 ressortissants français donc
ressortissant dotés de la nationalité
française et on est ensuite arrivé à ce
chiffre de 167 très précisément parce
qu'on y a ajouté euh leors ayant droit
euh donc leur famille et puis aussi nos
je vais revenir sur les chiffres plus
précis nos employés de de l'Institut
Français et leur famille également une
fois ce recensement fait il a fallu les
rassembler au plus près du point de
sortie de Rafa donc les faire se
déplacer du nord de la bande de Gaza
vers le sud de la bande de Gaza notre
consulat général à Jérusalem a aussi
fait un travail absolument remarquable
de contact au quotidien quand les
communications le permettaient avec
chacune de ses chacun de ses
ressortissants chacune de ses chacune de
ses familles jusqu'au moment où le
passage a été possible il s'est fait en
plusieurs temps je vous passe les les
chiffres à travers le à travers le le le
poste de de Rafa euh ils ont été
accueilli du côté égyptien donc à la
riche par une équipe qui était formée à
la fois de l'ambassade et du consulat
Auer et du centre de crise et de soutien
ils ont été transportés en bus euh euh
réservé par nos soins bien évidemment
entre Rafa et le Caire ééberger au CA à
l'hôtel et les Égyptiens nous avaient
dit vous avez 72 heur pour pouvoir les
embarquer et les rapatrier chez vous ce
qui nous a laissé le temps aussi
d'émettre d'établir les documents de
voyage quand c'était nécessaire pour
pour rentrer en France au total
aujourd'hui on comptabilise 117
personnes ressortissant français ou
agents de droit local de notre institut
et leur famille qui ont ainsi pu sortir
de Gaza et pour être très précis 49
français et 20 3 membres de leur famille
et 7 de nos agents de droit local et 33
membres de leur famille qui maintenant
donc sont en France ils sont arrivé en
deux groupes successifs le vendredi 5
novembre et euh non le dimanche 5
novembre j'étais le dimanche 5 novembre
et le vendredi 10 novembre avec un
dispositif identique à celui qu'on avait
mis en place pour nos ressortissant
d'Israël c'est-à-dire une une cellule
d'urgence médico-psychologique un
dispositif médical sanitaire euh
l'ensemble de ces ces services de
soutien et d'accompagnement qui qui
peuvent être déployés dans ces dans ces
circonstance et aussi l'association
France horizon qui qui leur a trouvé des
solutions d'hébergement d'urgence donc
ça c'était pour répondre à votre
question sur qu'est-ce qu'on a fait pour
les ressortissants français et et ceux
qui le qui leur sont assimulé assimilé
et voilà où nous en sommes aujourd'hui
euh pour ce qui concerne l'INE
humanitaire je vois que le temps
file un certain nombre de je vais vous
faire un certain nombre de de remarques
puis je répondrai à vos questions
d'abord sur le contexte et les besoins
je vais pas m'aesantir parce que vous le
connaissez aussi bien que moi il a été
décrit je crois dans des termes très
justes et à la fois très préoccupants et
très émouvant par le commissaire général
de nunois Philippe Lazarini en ouverture
de la conférence internationalist
humanitaire du du 9 novembre et il nous
a dit à quel point la situation sur
place était dramatique il a souligné le
manque de file d'eau
euh de produits alimentaires de base il
nous a dit à quel point les hôpitaux
étaient débordés au point que la plupart
d'entre eux ne fonctionnent plus
aujourd'hui il nous a dit la
surpopulation dans les abrri puisque une
grande partie de la population Gazaoui
s'est déplacée du Nord vers les vers le
sud
il nous a dit les quartiers rasés enfin
les images que que que que que vous avez
vu h ça c'est la c'est la la première
chose mais qu' est important de qui est
important de de rappeler parce que ça
donne une idée de l'ampleur des des
besoins aujourd'hui constatés et qui le
seront certainement à forceuie plus
encore dans les dans les jours dans les
jours qui viennent première remarque
deuxième remarque cette conférence qui a
été convoquée organisée en très peu de
temps he une semaine en fait 10 jours
maximum a
permis un certain nombre d'annonces
financières qui sont qui sont
importantes puisque'au total avec les
cavates que vous disiez monsieur
monsieur le Président tout à l'heure
c'est 1 milliard d'euros qui ont été
annoncés il faut les mettre en il faut
mettre ce milliard
d'euros regard des besoins qui avaient
été définis identifiés par par les
Nations Unies notamment le bureau de
coordination des affaires humanitaires
Martin gffis qui était qui participé à
cette conférence et qu' est chiffré à
date à 1,2 milliards euh donc on n'est
pas très loin de la marque sachant que
cette marque elle va progressivement
bien évidemment euh grandir au fur à
mesure que exactement
h donc 1 milliard d'annonce de
contribution et pour ce qui concerne la
France un soutien humanitaire aux
populations
palestinienne qui est porté à 100
millions d'euros et je vais vous
détailler euh un peu plus précisément ce
que sont ces 100 millions parce que je
crois qu'il eu un certain nombre de
d'ambiguitïé à ce à ce propos
premièrement l'aide à la Palestine au
Palestiniens de manière générale ne date
pas de cette crise évidemment et sur
2023 avant donc même les les annonces
faites à la suite du du à la suite des
attentats du du 7 octobre la France
consacrait 82 millions d'euros à la
Palestine au palestin qui se divise
moitié pour moitié
entre l'aide humanitaire d'une part et
l'aide au développement d'autre
part et quand je ce cite de 82 million
d'euros je je je je vise non seulement
Gaza mais aussi la la sidjordanie et
Jérusalem ça passe beaucoup pour ce qui
concerne l'aide humanitaire par deux
consortium qui sont présents
respectivement en sixjordanie et à Gaza
et qui en fait rassembl
l'essentiel sinon la totalité des
grandes ONG spécialisées dans l'urgence
humanitaire qui s'agit d'ailleurs de
d'ONG française ou d'ONG international
je pense à NC Act de première urgence
internationale handicap internationale
enfin bref elles sont toutes un titre ou
un autre dans ces dans ces deux
consortiums respectivement
respectivement pour la sjordanie et pour
la bande de de de Gaza ça c'est pour
2023 avant le 7 octobre on y a ajouté
après le 7 octobre 20 millions d'euros
qui ont été annoncés en deux temps par
la ministre des Affaires étrangères
respectivement le le 16 et le 21 octobre
donc 10 + 10 20 millions supplémentaires
qui sont annoncés dans cette première
quinzaine d'octobre enfin autour de
autour de la
mi-octobre et en plus de ces 20 millions
là on monte à 100 millions donc plus 80
millions annoncé par le président de la
République au moment de la conférence
humanitaire du du 9 compositions sans
entrer trop dans le détail mais je
pourrais vous la communiquer si vous le
souhaitez de ces 100 millions c'est 77
millions d'euros via les agences des
Nations Unies dont 54 millions pour
l'unra c'est 6 million d'euros via le
CICR et dans un cas comme dans l'autre
d'ailleurs on vise
essentiellement les secteur de
concernant les besoins de base
c'est-à-dire l'alimentation l'eau la
nourriture les abris la santé la
protection particulier des femmes et des
enfants et c'est enfin 17 millions pour
les
on française et internationales
partenair donc c qui sont d'ors et déjà
présentes dans la bande de Gaza et là
aussi on parle de d'accès au service de
base on parle aussi de prépositionnement
d'un certain nombre de
stocks notamment avec des kits d'hygiène
des tentes parce que la météo commence à
devenir mauvaise et on va en avoir grand
besoin dans les dans les jours dans les
dans les semaines qui les semaines qui
viennent donc voilà le la
décomposition de de de de ces 100
millions qui ont été annoncés de ce qui
se faisait par ailleurs avant avant ces
événements dramatiques du du 7
octobre
deè deuxème grande action qui est menée
par le Centre de Crise vous avez
peut-être entendu parler c'est l'envoi
de fret humanitaire sur
place on en est à plus d'une centaine de
tonnes aujourd'hui de fret euh 54 tonnes
dans trois avions dans un premier temps
qui étaient des
avions du du CPCO donc des armées
françaises essentiellement des
équipements médicaux des médicaments
euh des des ce qu'on appelle des
suppléments
nutritionnels des générateurs des lampes
solaires enfin du fret humanitaire de
manière générale 54 tonnes en TR en 3
vols un vol supplémentaire de 33 tonnes
qui est un vol de de don d'une
entreprise qui appppelle nutriet qui est
passé par le pont aérien de de de
l'union de
l'Union européenne mais c'est un peu une
c'est c'est très élémentaire par très
peu par rapport à l'ensemble des besoins
par définition où est-ce que ça tombe
alors l'ensemble l'ensemble de cette
aide est envoyé à à la riche parce que
les Égyptiens ont décidé de faire de
àariche àarich est à 45 minutes de
voiture du du du du point de passage de
Rafa d'accord
euh en Égypte en Égypte al Laar est à la
fois euh une une une base aérienne
militaire et un
port et donc les Égyptiens demandent que
toute tout le fret humanitaire arrive
par àal rich la décision que nous avons
prise c'est de remettre notre aide
humanitaire au au Croissant Rouge
égyptien qui la remet cette aide
humanitaire au croiss rouge palestinien
tout simplement parce que le Croissant
Rouge a des accès et une possibilité de
passage par Rafa qu'aucun autre pays n'a
aujourd'hui on sait
aujourd'hui alors le nombre de camions
qui passe par Rafa varie d'un jour à
l'autre mais grosso modo il doit être
aujourd'hui je même pas dire ça comme ça
mais stabiliser à moins de 100 camions
par jour là où les agences tusiennes
estiment qu'il en faudrait entre 400 et
500 vous voyez la la la le gap qu'il y a
aujourd'hui à remplir pour pour répondre
véritablement au défi humanitaire qui
est qui est qui est devant
nous je vais essayer de de de de
conclure rapidement de façon à laisser
un peu de temps pour répondre à vos à
vos à vos à vos à vos questions juste
pour vous dire un mot de ce qu'on
envisage pour la
suite d'abord ce qui était aussi
intéressant au moment de cette
conférence humanitaire du 9
c'est d'entendre de très nombreuses euh
initiatives venant des des nombreux pays
une soixantaine de délégations réunies à
l'Élysée j'en cite juste quelques-unes
le le corridor maritime humanitaire
chipriote l'envoi sur zone de navir par
les Pays-Bas et l'Italie le renforcement
du soutien de la Jordanie à son
hôpital de Gaza d'ailleurs avec le
soutien français l'accueil de mineur
blessé par les Émirats Arabe Unis et
cetera et cetera donc il y a
euh beaucoup il y a un élan que que que
qu'on sent et et et bien évidemment il
va falloir que non seulement nous à
titre bilatéral on continue voir on on
augmente l'aide que nous avons d'ors et
déjà apporté qu'on va continuer à
apporter mais il va falloir qu'on
travaille bien évidemment avec
l'ensemble de de ses partenaires à
commencé par les partenaires européens
je citais le le le pont le pont aérien
not
il y a il y a deux
grandes pour faire vraiment les choses
au plus court il y a il y a deux grands
sujet de grands secteurs vers lesquels
nous nous orientons la poursuite des
acheminements de frit humanitaire sur
les différents secteurs qui ont été
identifiés d'une part on peut le faire
de différentes manières par voie
aérienne par voie maritime à titre
bilatéral en nous insérant dans des dans
des dans des
initiatives multi
et pour répondre à différents besoins
qui vont se manifester au fur et à
mesure que la crise va évoluer ça c'est
la première chose la deuxième chose
qu'on qu'on qu'on va faire c'est
concentrer notre
aide c'est une instruction qui nous est
donnée par le Président de la République
de façon à ce que la France devienne
nation cadre aussi pour ce secteur qui
est le secteur sanitaire en
particulier et donc c'est ça consiste à
la fois en la fourniture de matériel
dans le financement d'un certain nombre
d'hôpitaux comme on l'a fait avec la
Jordanie comm on pourrait le faire avec
l'Égypte a déployé aussi des capacités
médicales de différentes manières vous
avez entendu parler notamment des des
portes hélicoptères à laquelle auquel
vous faisiez référence monsieur le
Président on peut aussi on regarde ce
qu'on pourrait faire pour pour soigner
des blessés qui aujourd'hui sont
hospitalisés à Gaza avec les difficultés
avec les difficultés qu'on sait donc
voilà c'est pas euh exclusive d'autres
projets qu'on pourra qu'on pourra
soutenir bien évidemment mais c'est ce
que je voulais vous dire
ce soir en vous priant de m'excuser
d'avoir été déjà beaucoup trop long pas
du tout vous savez il beaucoup de choses
à dire écoutez je vous remercie
infiniment je crois que
c'est très réconfortant de de voir à
quel point l'administration français se
mobilise avec ses moyens et avec ses
partenaires pour essayer d'apporter
un un minimum de
réconfort quelle que soit la forme notre
réconfort à
tous ces toutes ces personnes qui
souffrent que ce soit le ressortissants
qu'on a ramené que ce soit les gens qui
sont en cette situation humanitaire
terrible c'était très très
impressionnant maintenant les groupes
vont vous interroger plus précisément et
la première à intervenir c'est Madame
Piron qui est pour le groupe Renaissance
qui est député des
ivelines
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
Lalot au nom de notre groupe je vous
remercie pour votre présence au sein de
notre commission ainsi que pour votre
présentation de la situation
israélo-palestinien le 7 octobre dernier
comme vous l'avez dit 50 ans après la
guerre du Kipour le Hamas a lancé une
opération terroriste se traduisant par
le lancement de plusieurs milliers de
roquettes contre le territoire d'Israël
l'infiltration de dizaines de
terroristes armés dans le sud du pays
afin de provoquer des tueries de civiles
ainsi que la prise d'otage de civil et
de militaires emmené à gaz pour servir
de monnaie d'échange au total c'est plus
de 1200 morts et 2400 blessés lors de
ces attaques un bilan inédit depuis la
création de l'État d'Israël plus de 200
personnes sont également retenues en
otage la France déplore elle le décès de
40 sortissant français et de H disparus
dont certains kidnappés en réaction à
cela l'Israël a déclaré l'état de guerre
et a annoncé le bombardement ainsi que
le blocus complet de l'enclave de Gaza
le bilan de cette opération s'élève
provisoirement à environ 11000 morts
principalement des civils dont plus de
4000 enfants selon les informations
relayées par l'Agence France Presse lors
de leur déplacement dans la région le
président de la République ainsi que la
ministre de l'Europe et des Affaires
étrangères se sont entretenus avec les
familles des otages et ont condamné avec
la plus grande fermeté les attaques
terroristes menées par le Hamas ce
dimanche le Premier ministre israélien
Benjamin netanahou a évoqué la
possibilité d'un accord potentiel visant
à libérer les otages sans pour autant
détailler son plan d'action quel genre
de mesure le gouvernement français a
adopté ou pourrait adopter pour
faciliter la libération des otages
détenus dans la dans la bande de Gaza
parle-t-on uniquement des otages
français ou de tous les
otages dans ce contexte le Qatar a joué
aussi un rôle significatif dans les
négociations de libération et dans la
sécurisation du départ de de la bande de
Gaza des ressortissants étrangers et ou
bénationaux présents sur place peut-on
parler d'une stratégie commune entre la
France et le Qatar où chaque pays
négocie-t-il indépendamment enfin la
conférence tenue pour l'aide humanitaire
a évoqué près d'un milliard d'aide don
environ 100 millions d'euros venant de
la France il semble que la France est
envoyée de l'aide en materniel
principalement mais actuellement freiné
donc le nombre de camions par jour
serait environ de 100 par jour soit 5
par heure pourriez-vous nous dire plus
sur qui gère les passages parafat et et
qu'est-ce qui freine les arrivé d'aide
humanitaire je vous
remercie vous pouvez couper
merci vous répondez
monsieur pardon je suis désolé merci
Madame la député pour ces pour ces deux
questions je les prends
successivement d'abord celle sur les
cell sur les otages ou sur les les h
français disparus je vous l'ai dit tout
à l'heure ce sont des matières et c'est
vrai parce que malheureusement nous
avons des otages dans d'autres pays du
monde c'est vrai de manière générale on
reste toujours d'une très grande
discrétion d'une très
grande en respectant la plus grande des
confidentialités pour ces sur sur ces
questions
euh ce que je peux vous dire c'est
que on on on a des contacts qui sont des
contacts qui passent notamment par un
certain nombre de nos grands partenaires
euh dont nous savons qu'ils ont des
accès que nous avons pas vous en avez
cité un certain nombre le Qatar
l'Égypte et quelques
autres j'entrerai d'autant moins dans le
détail que pour être très honnête avec
vous ça ne reliève pas de la compétence
du centre de crise et de soutien et on
se tient à un cloisonnement très
strict chaque service étant dans dans sa
compétence et son couloir ce qui relève
de la compétence du centre de crise et
de soutien c'est d'être auprès des
familles c'estàdire de nous assurer que
les familles de nos
ressortissants bénéficient de tout le
soutien et de toute l'aide dont elles
ont besoin c'est la raison pour laquelle
nous sommes associés aux rencontres qui
ont lieu qui ont eu lieu non seulement
entre la ministre et ses familles euh y
compris sur place vous l'avez vous
l'avez dit mais aussi le président de la
République y compris sur place et y
compris en visionférence pour y avoir
participé depuis
l'Élysée il y a de ça quelques
quelques semaines maintenant euh donc
encore une fois je je je je vous en
dirai pas plus sinon réaffirmer la
l'extrême détermination de l'ensemble
des services de l'État qui à un titre ou
à un autre ont à connaître de ces on à
connaître de ces de ces sujets
malheureusement euh et ce faisant encore
une fois c'est pas une c'est pas une ni
une attitude ni une méthode qui est qui
est
propre non mais ni une attitude ni une
méthode qui est propre à à ce cas
particulier c'est c'est c'est le c'est
le c'est la doctrineénale la doctrine
générale exactement euh ça c'est pour ce
qui concerne les les otages pour ce qui
concerne
l'anumanitaire je vous l'ai dit tout à
l'heure et vous l'avez rappelé euh il y
a euh euh un gap important euh pour dire
pour dire les choses par euphémisme
entre ce qui passe aujourd'hui euh et ce
qui et ce qui devrait ce qui devrait
passer si on voulait
euh euh arrivé aux besoins qui sont
constatés encore une fois non pas par
nous par les agences des Nations unies
ou les grandes ONG qui qui sont
présentes sur place sur place à Gaza
eu sur ces
sujets nous nous
dépendons de ceux qui qui qui gèent qui
gèent le point de passage de Rafa c'est
en l'occurrence les
Égyptiens qui gère tous les point de
passage de la bombe de Gaza on pourrait
tout à fait envisager que l'aide
humanitaire entre par d'autres points
que le seul point de Rafa ça n'est pas
le cas aujourd'hui et on espère que ça
sera le cas ça ça sera le cas à l'avenir
ça ne doit pas être une raison pour nous
de de
ralentir le rythme des livraisons que
nous envisageons pour pour le pour la
population civile de de Gaza euh parce
qu'encore une fois tôt tout tard il
faudra laisser passer cette aide et
venir en aide à ces gens pour ce dont
ils ont
besoin merci pour le rassemblement
national c'est madame la députée de la
Somme madame
ménache merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Directeur la situation de
crise grave en Israël et dans les
Territoires palestiniens projette le
CDCS au cœur de ces missions dans celle
de la protection des ressortissants
français le contexte les rend
particulièrement difficiles à mettre en
œuvre entre les méthodes condamnables du
Hamas dès l'attaque du 7 octobre
structure civil habitation exécution de
civil sans défense enlèvement et prise
d'otage danst de nombreux ressortissants
français il faut le rappeler et les
victime innocent consécutives au
bombardement de la bande de Gaza le CDCS
doit agir dans des conditions
inextricables nous saluons les efforts
consentis notamment pour assurer l'envoi
d'aide humanitaire 88 tonnes de matériel
humanitaire ont déjà été envoyé au
croissant rougge égyptien secours
médecine éclairage et production
d'énergie tente nourriture tablettes et
de décontamination pardon pour l'eau sur
ce point nous nous souhaitons savoir
pourquoi il n'a pas été possible de
remettre cette aide directement sans
passer par le croissant
égyptien dans un but humanitaire sans
remettre en cause le droit d'Israël de
se défendre nous soutenons la position
qui consiste à demander un cesser le feu
la position de la France dans ce conflit
est délicate et nous comprenons qu'il
est indispensable de maintenir des
contacts significatifs avec le Qatar
principal bailleur de fond du Hamas afin
d'obtenir la libération de ceux de nos
ressortissants retenus en otage à son
niveau le CDCS a-t-il des relations
directes et lesquelles avec les
protagonistes du conflit nous tenons
aussi à exprimer notre trouble quant à
la destination de l'aide européenne
décidée par Madame Van Leyen dont le
Canard enchaîné dans son édition du 8
novembre dit que les familles de
quelques 1500 terroristes du Hamas tué
ou capturés seront dédommagés par
l'Autorité palestinienne grâce en parti
aux quelques 300 millions d'euros d'aide
annuelle que celle-ci reçoit de l'Union
européenne à ce sujet Quelles sont les
relations que le CDCS entretient avec
les actions diplomatiques ou
humanitaires de l'Union européenne je
vous
remercie je vous remercie madame la
députée Monsieur le
Directeur merci monsieur le président
madame la députée merci pour pour ces
trois questions j'essayie de les prendre
dans l'ordre euh pourquoi le Croissant
Rouge euh pour développer un peu ce que
je vous disais tout à l'heure c'est pour
une raison d'efficacité essentiellement
c'est-à-dire que c'est le Croissant
Rouge qui a les meilleurs accès puisque
lui-même traite ensuite avec le
Croissant Rouge palestinien donc en fait
nous remettons l'aide au Croissant Rouge
égyptien qui ensuite remet cette aide au
Croissant Rouge palestinien et c'est
donc la manière la plus rapide euh de
délivrer l'aide à ceux à qui elle est
destinée c'est une pure raison de une
pure raison
d'efficacité première question deuxème
question est-ce que le CDCS a des
relations avec les parties au conflit ma
réponse va être lapidaire je vous prie
de m'en excuser non le le rôle du du du
du CDCS encore une fois comme vous le
releviez très très
justement c'est d'assurer la protection
des Français et c'est
de participer à la à l'action
humanitaire de de la France en aucune
manière
d'intervenir d'un côté ou de l'autre d'
d'une crise ou d'un d'une crise ou d'un
conflit nous laissons ça à d'autres la
dernière question sur sur l'Union
européenne l'essentiel aujourd'hui de
notre relation avec l'Union européenne
elle est d'ordre logistique c'est-à-dire
que les les premières livraisons de de
fretes humanitaires nous les avons monté
euh euh avec des avions euh affraités
par nous en l'occurrence des avions
militaires français c'est les trois
premiers qui ont qui ont transporté les
54 premières
tonnes l'avion suivant il en en a deux
autres qui sont programmés sont
programmé dans le cadre de ce qu'on
appelle le pont aérien de l'Union
européenne c'est-à-dire la noria des
avions qui sont utilisés par les
différents pays de l'Union européenne
qui souhaitent livrer de l'aide
humanitaire ou du fret humanitaire sur
place et qui qui qui utilise qui
utilisees ces moyens le système est bien
rodé maintenant je dois ajouter un autre
contact qu'on a avec avec l'Union
européenne et qui me vient je suis
désolé en en en vous répondant il y
a à Bruxelles des instances qui sont des
instances d'échange d'information
euh euh où où les
États-membres volontairement et
discrétionnairement euh peuvent partager
de de l'information sur le nombre de
leurs ressortissants qui sont passés par
par le par le passage de Rafa le nombre
de ressortissants qui leur reste qui
peuvent éventuellement demander par ce
biais de l'aide à un autre pays
ressortissant qui peuvent demander si
nous avons des dans le jargon des
vecteurs aériens ou maritimes qui
permettrai d'emmener du fret et cetera
et cetera donc il y a aussi ces
plateformes qui sont en fait une espèce
de plateforme informatique sur
lesquelles nous sommes tous branchés qui
permettent de faire de faire mais
vraiment c'est vraiment les
de l'échange d'information basique mais
c'est très utile euh de façon à pouvoir
se s'y retrouver à éviter les
redondances euh
aussi je vous remercie maintenant c'est
pour la France insoumise et Monsieur Le
Gal Monsieur Le Gal est député du
valdoise merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Directeur merci pour votre
présentation d'abord je voudrais rendre
hommage au centre de crise et de soutien
euh dont dont on connaît tous la très
grande
compétence mais au-delà de sa fonction
purement humanitaire il a il a incarné
ici une forme d'unité de la nation en
s'occupant indifféremment des citoyens
français présents en Israël ou des
citoyens français présents à Gaza même
si si on sait que ça a été parfois plus
compliqué de les de localiser les
exfiltrés de Gaza mais pour des raisons
qui ne tiennent pas évidemment à vos
services mais qui tenaient à la
situation sur
place euh également vous avez rappelé
donc les besoins immense en aide
humanitaire vous avez rappelé le travail
que fait l'unra sur place les agents de
l'ONU travaille trop souvent décrié en
ce moment je voudrais aussi rendre
hommage aux 102 agents de l'ONU qui sont
morts à Gaza parmi les civils
palestiniens et donc vous avez rappelé
également que la France a par dans la
conférence organisée à Paris récemment
obtenu 1 milliard de promesses de don
euh la France elle-même ayant donné 100
millions alors ça correspond à peu près
aux besoins théoriques à ce stadeant
donné que ces besoins en en raison du
siège illégal je le
rappelle que subit lap toute une
population ses besoins ne vont faire que
s' croître mais le vrai sujet c'est donc
de savoir comment ça va passer comment
cette tête va passer donc vous avez
donné des chiffres 100 camions par jour
à l'heure actuelle passe il en faudrait
au minimum 400 ou 500 je rappelle
qu'avant avant l'opération actuelle on
était à 600 camions par jour avez-vous
vous des informations concernant la
possibilité d'une hausse du nombre de de
camions dans un avenir proche et par
ailleurs confirmez-vous les informations
qui sont pasfois remises en question ici
selon lesquels si les camions ne passent
pas c'est aussi parce que certaines
zones de passage étaient elles-même
bombardées ou en tout cas était
elle-même cible de bombardement
potentiel ce qui empêchait les camions
de passé je vous remercie pour vos
éclairages sur ce sujet et enfin
dernière chose je voudrais dire que et
ça ça ne relève pas de vos services il
est très important et il est même
urgent que la situation qui perdure
depuis des décennies qui est que l'aide
humanitaire et finalement sert entre
guillemets à remplacer une solution
politique qui n'arrive pas il faut
absolument qu'il y ait une solution
politique qui soit trouvée parce que on
peut pas vivre éternellement d'aide
humanitaire ou survivre éternellement
d'aide
humanitaire je vous remercie monsieur le
député Monsieur le Directeur voulez-vous
répondre à Monsieur Le Gal je répondra
avec grand plaisir monsieur le
Président merci d'abord merci à vous
puis à toutes celles et tous ceux qui je
transmettrai à mon équipe qui sera très
sensible qui nous ont remercier pour
pour ce qui éta fait au Centre de Crise
de manière générale d'ailleurs par le
ministèreur des Affaires
étrangères s'agissant
[Musique]
de votre première remarque je ve
insister sur sur et vous parliez d'union
nationale au cas particulier non
seulement nous avons mis un point
d'honneur et c'est une obligation qui
nous est faite à nous occuper et à
rapatrier ce qui le souhaitaent de nos
ressortissants de nos
compatriotes mais nous avons rapatrier
aussi certains de nos employés certains
de nos salariés je le signalis tout à
l'heure de l'Institut français de Gaza
qui sont des Palestiniens et on en tire
une grande fierté
euh s'agissant de personnel qui euh
travaille avec nous nous travaillons
avec eux depuis depuis longtemps déjà
certains d'entre eux je le signalais en
introduction depuis près d'une d'une
vingtaine d'années donc non seulement
d'ailleurs n nos employés mais aussi le
leurs famillees leurs ayant drroit qui
qui sont arrivés on en est très content
en sécurité maintenant ici à Paris ça
c'est la première chose la deuxième
chose ce n'estut pas une question mais
je tiens à me joindre à ce que vous
venez de dire sur les personnels de
lunra euh sans de morts dans leur rang
c'est un très très lourd
tribu payé par cette agence des Nations
Unies vous avez dit qu'elle était décrié
je do dire que c'est la fierté de la
France que de la soutenir et d'avoir
encore augmenté son
soutien dans les dans les dans les dans
la période dans les jours dans les jours
récents j'ai eu la chance de
m'entretenir avec Philippe nazarini la
veille de de la conférence et je dois
dire j'étis très impressionné parce
qu'il m'a dit de ce que faisait lunra
dans toute cette zone dans tous les
camps pas simplement dans la dans la
bande de Gaza mais mais dans d'autres
camps qui sont déployés qui sont déployé
dans la région sagant du nombre des
camions je dois vous avouer que je suis
incapable de répondre à cette question
euh on constate tous encore une fois
l'écart qui existe entre ce qui se fait
et ce qu'il faudrait ce qu'il faudrait
faire
eu on espère tous que cet écart sera
comblé sera comblé au plus vite
euh et c'est vrai des différentes
euh de tout ce qui peut passer par par
ces points de passage et je répète ce
que je je disais tout à l'heure à la
députée à Madame
Piron il y a pas que Rafa par lequel on
peut entrer dans la bande de Gaza et
donc il faudrait
que l'ensemble des points de passage
puissent être ouvert de façon à laisser
passer l' humanitaire au au plus
vite de la même manière je suis d'accord
avec vous
l'humanitaire n'est pas un substitut à
une solution
politique et c'est la raison pour
laquelle je vous disais en introduction
que l'approche française elle elle
repous sur ces trois
piliers pris séparément fonctionnant
ensemble et non pas l'un à l'exclusion
au détriment de l'autre qui sont un
pilier sécuritaire un pilier humanitaire
et un pilier politique il n'y aura de
solution dissue à à ce conflit que si
nous poursuivons nos objectifs
dans ces trois dimensions
là je vous remercie maintenant c'est
pour le modem c'est Monsieur Frédéric
petit monsieur Frédéric petit est député
des Français de l'étranger pour une
grande partie de l'Europe du Nord de
l'Est de l'est et du Sud-Est monsieur le
Président merci monsieur le Président je
veux pas vous faire marcher sur les
brisées de Monsieur hroy voilà merci
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Directeur merci pour votre exposé je je
je me joins à aux louanges qui ont été
fait au CDCS je voudrais rappeler aussi
que c'est une organisation assez récente
vous l'avez rappelé c'est une
organisation très innovante comme quoi
notre ministère des Affaires étrangères
est capable dans cette période de d'être
innovant et d'être efficace et j'en suis
très fier je voulais vous poser une
question moi sur un sujet dont mes
collègues savent qu'il me touche
beaucoup et que je suis avec beaucoup
d'insistance dans le cadre de la du du
rapport 185 euh vous l'avez fait
d'ailleurs vous en avez parlé
c'est le rôle d'employeur de la France
le rôle d'employeur des non français et
je vais même ajouter des employeur le
rôle d'employeur direct ou indirect je
suis ravi d'apprendre que nous avons
pensé à évacuer et à protéger nos
salariés locaux de l'Institut français
je rappelle à mes collègues que nous
avons d'autres salariés locaux
d'organisation française nous avons nous
avons des chercheurs de laafd nous avons
des gens sur place c'est un sujet auquel
je tiens beaucoup qui m'a souvent été
que ce soit en crise ou pas en crise
auquel j'ai souvent été confronté avec
les service j'ai parfois j'ai dit à un
ministre que je trouvais que nous
n'étions pas le meilleur employeur local
souvent et surtout ce que je reproche et
ce que j'aimerais travailler et ma
question va porter sur le fait que vous
avez dit devoir moral moi je crois que
c'est un devoir diplomatique c'est un
devoir d'exemplarité et je je je
voudrais vous interroger sur la
systémisation la systémisation vous avez
dit on l'a fait parce que ça nous a
semblé important et cetera moi je pense
que c'est un devoir permanent et je
parle aussi d'indirect j'avais posé la
question je suis au conseil
d'administration de de la FD j'ai posé
la question au moment du Niger en disant
nos salariés diplomatiques nos salariés
directs et puis nous avons envoyé des
ONG nous avons financé des ONG qui
partent avec du personnel et ma question
va être très simple y a-t-il un travail
au centre de crise donc je sais que vous
êtes extrêmement bien organisé y y
a-t-il un travail de
recensement en général un travail de
construction d'un recensement pour que
nous ayons un avis sur tout ces
personnels le personnel donc des
Français je sais comment c'est recensé
je sais que parfois c'est pas recensé je
sais je suis bien placé pour le savoir
il vote pas il vote pas ce mais est-ce
qu'il y a un travail de recensement des
des employés direct et des employés
indirects que nous envoyons au quatre
coins du monde porter notre drapeau
merci
Monsieur le
Directeur merci monsieur le
député d'un mot le CDCS en effet une une
structure récente elle remonte à 2008
donc elle fait sa 15e année cette année
et c'est une structure qui a qui est
montée en puissance de manière très
rapide une trentaine de TP une trentaine
d'agents à sa création il y en a 60 en
2014 il y en a 110 aujourd'hui euh c'est
vrai également des crédits qui lui sont
confié vous sa mieux que personne euh je
crois qu'on devit être à 100 millions de
crédits humanitaires en 2001 200
millions en 2022 300 millions à la fin
de cette année et on est en train
d'examiner le PLF de 2024 c'est le
reflet de l'état du monde hein aussi
cette espèce de d'augmentation de
superposition d'allongement de la durée
des crises euh qui fait que
euh que le centre a trouvé euh sa raison
d'être sa légitimité
euh dans ces dans ces moments-là euh ça
c'était la première remarque la deuxième
remarque elle nous emmènerait loin et
jeis tout près en discuter avec vous
sur quel est notre politique en tant
qu'employeur vis-à-vis de ce qu'on
appelle dans le jargon nos ADL d'une
part euh ou d'autre part en effet les
salariés qui sont notamment les salariés
de nos opérateurs sit la FD si gardé il
y en a d'autres
euh alors quand en savoir si on a un
ressence ces personnels oui quand à
savoir s'il est consolidé au CDCS non ça
n'est pas sa ça n'est pas sa mission le
CDCS fait beaucoup de choses mais fait
pas ça au régime de croisière la
question se pose pour le CDCS en période
de crise quand quand quand se pose la
question du du rapatriment
l'évacuation pour ne rien vous cacher
dans le cas qui nous occupe pour ce qui
concerne la bande de
Gaza ayant
évacué la totalité à une exception
près des ressortissants français qui le
souhaitaent de la bande de
Gaza nous regardons maintenant ce qu'il
en
est d'autres personnes que nous
pourrions vouloir parce qu'il nous
sollicite évacuer ça pose des problèmes
redoutables notamment de dans les
conditions les modalités de
sortie vis-à-vis de ceux qui tiennent
les points de passage également dans les
modalités accueil sur le territoire
français parce que bien évidemment un
ressortissant français a tous les droits
de vouloir rentrer chez lui euh dès lors
qu'on est sur des nationalité tierce ça
ça pose des des des questions lié au
titre de séjour lié aux conditions
d'hébergement et cetera et cetera mais
c'est quelque chose et pour tout vous
dire nous sommes aujourd'hui très
sollicités par par des grandes
ONG notamment par
certaines organisations de la société
civile ou par certaines agences des
Nations Unies euh qui nous interroge sur
le point de savoir si on pourrait les
aider à à sortir leur personnel de de
Gaza donc c'est un travail qui est en
qui est en
cours je vous remercie euh maintenant
pour les socialiste c'est monsieur le
député de la Gironde Monsieur Alain
David qui va s'exprimer merci merci
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Directeur mes chers
collègues merci monsieur le directeur
pour cet éclairage à la fois sur sur la
situation des des huit Français qui
pourraient encore être détenus dans la
dans la barne de Gaza depuis leur
enlèvement et et sur les personnes
récemment évacuées par le point de
passage de Rafa vers l'Égypte où ils ont
été pris en charge par vos par vos
équipes et à ce propos j'imagine que la
suite de votre travail va nécessiter la
plus grande
discrétion pour le reste des opérations
et en particulier c'est peu compatible
avec les les besoins des des proches et
des familles qui veulent à tout prix
recevoir des informations afin de faire
vivre
l'espoir pour cela avec les collègues de
mon groupe des députés socialistes et
apparentés nous vous sommes très
reconnaissants et nous saluons le
travail de la diplomatie
française en général et de votre service
en
particulier j'imagine que la situation
actuelle est assez inédite et sans
rapport avec les crises que vous avez
connu précédemment lié à des événements
soit Météor ologique sismique la
pandémie de covid rapatriant
rapatriement de nos ressortissants
d'Afghanistan les évacuations suite au
coups d'État en Afrique ou la guerre en
Ukraine pourriez-vous nous dire ce qui
selon vous caractérise spécifiquement la
la crise cette crise en Israël et dans
les Territoires
palestiniens regarde vos missions
d'assistance d'aide humanitaire de
soutien aux familles ou proches des
victimes est-ce que on on parle de 40
victimes
identifiées mais on on na pas parlé de
de rapatriment des des victimes de
certaines victimes parce que je suppose
que un certain nombre resteront en
Israël mais y y a-t-il un nombre
important de de victimes qui vont être
rapatriées et avez-vous entendu parler
ou peut-on espérer un hommage national
au victimes de de ces conflits et en
particulier également la décision d'un
jour de deuil national pour en hommage à
ses victimes
voilà simplement mes interrogations mais
j'attends pas de ce côté-là une réponse
bien sûr de votre part parce que je
pense que c'est à un autre niveau que
cette décision se prendrait mais les
Français l'attendent beaucoup et
s'interrogent beaucoup sur le fait
pourquoi n'y a-t-il pas d'ommage
national ou ou de jour de deuil national
je je crains cher Alain que c'est vous
venez de le dire que ce ne soit pas le
monsieur le directeur du Centre qui
puisse nous nous répondre envche ça
serait la matière d'une intéressante
question au gouvernement oui donc car
c'est le gouvernement qui a qui a
compéten pour vous pour vous répondre et
je crois que j'ai dit à Monsieur le
Directeur je n'attendais pas de répondre
de ça oui oui oui c'est les meilleures
questions qu'on peut
poser Monsieur le Directeur allez-y
c'est une question sans réponse c'est me
réponse qu'on
PE
pardon je vais quand même vous donner un
élément de réponse parce qu'il me semble
que en matière d'hommage le président de
la République s'est exprimé et
détromp-moi si je me trompe mais il a
dit que cet hommage serait organisé
quand le bilan serait définitif ça
rejoint ce que je vous disais tout à
l'heure c'est que pour l'instant le
bilan des victimes est de de 40
mais nous ne sommes pas sûrs que le
bilan reste là je crains malheureusement
qu'il qu'il m dans les jours dans les
jours qui viennent euh euh quand à
savoir si ces victimes devont être euh
rapatrié beaucoup d'entre elles étaient
installé depuis longtemps en en Israël
c'est le cas aussi des familles de de
nos disparus pour vous dire les choses
très très honnêtement parmi les huit par
exemple euh SEP d'entre elles familles
sont en totalité installées en Israël
donc c'est notre notre consulat général
à TelAviv et notre ambassade qui les qui
les aide qui les accompagne qui qui ont
le contact avec elle le CDCS lui a le
contact avec une de ses familles une des
H qui est installé dans le sud de la
France je ser pas plus précis ici donc
vous voyez le le le le partage et puis
c'est une question qui viendra en son
temps je crois auquel bien évidemment on
sera attentif parce que ça fait partie
ça fait partie des sujets qu'il faudra
traiter à l'avenir vous me demandiez ce
qui était particulier à cette à cette
crise alors là je pense que ça nous
emmènerait très très loin moi j'y vois
trois caractéristiques
euh qu'on retrouve dans certaines crises
mais qui sont très particulières à
celles-là la première c'est l'intensité
et et et la vitesse à laquelle la crise
est est montée en puissance
h on a connu d'autres crises intenses je
pense à ce qui s'est passé en Ukraine
par exemple euh mais celle-ci a une un
pouvoir de
conflagration qui est qui lui est très
particulier et c'est ce qui la rend
aussi inquiétante ça c'est la première
chose la deuxième chose c'est la
complexité de cette crise dire toutes
les crises sont complexes dans quelques
nature qu'elle soit d'ailleurs en effet
mais celle-ci atteint un
niveau de complexité dans son
environnement régional avec une une
capacité à de contagion sur ses marges à
sa périphérie qui est quand même très
remarquable euh et puis la troisème la
troisème chose la trè caractéristique
euh c'est la durée dans laquelle euh je
crains que nous nous installions je vois
mal cette crise être réglée dans les 15
jours qui viennent ni même dans les 6
mois qui viennent euh
elle elle elle existe déjà depuis des
décennies on avait peut-être eu tendance
à la à la minorer en minorer
l'importance elle revient de manière
très brutale très violente
très très traumatisante aussi euh et
encore une fois je crains que que ça que
ça dure et ça dure longtemps donc
intensité complexité et durée c'est les
trois caractéristiques qui me viennent
et qui donnent d'ailleurs une idée des
des difficultés auxquell auxquelles nous
sommes confrontés
affrontés
le
les exigences de la séance publique font
que il avais trois orateurs qui devaient
encore intervenir mais ils ont été
appelés par leur groupe j'imagine pour
ce ce aller en séance publique donc
la la prise de parole par les groupes
est terminé mais j'ai encore deux
parlementaires qui souhaite et qui ont
je leur laisse volontiers 2 minutes et
demi et pas une minute parce que nous
nous n'avons pas nous avons c'est Madame
madame soud pour la France insoumise
puis monsieur Guignot pour le
rassemblement national hercila c'est à
vous merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Directeur vous parliez de
trois piliers de l'approche française
vis-à-vis de la situation
israëlo-palestinienne un pilier
sécuritaire un pilier humanitaire et un
pilier politique il est vrai que pendant
longtemps c'est une position d'équilibre
qui a iser la diplomatie française au
Moyen-Orient mais depuis la présidence
de Nicolas Sarkozi le curseur a changé
se plaçant plutôt du côté israélien à la
suite du drame du 7 octobre Emmanuel
Macron a mis en avant le soutien de la
France à Israël et son droit à se
défendre depuis le voilà rattrapé par la
réalité des massacres perpétré par
Israël à l'encontre des Gazaoui et par
le poids de l'opinion publique il a
exhorté Israël à ne pas tuer d'innocent
et il l' appelé un cesser le feu alors
voilà Benjamin netaniiaahou et son
ministre de la Défense qui lui tape sur
les doigts contraignant Emmanuel Macron
a réitéré son soutien à à
Israël Monsieur le Directeur comment la
voix de la France peut-elle être audible
dans ces conditions et cela ne fragilise
ne fragilise-t-il pas le pilier
politique que vous
évoquiez impératoria AB Vitas madame
soude
euh répondez Monsieur le Directeur je
sais pas si vous êtes en mesure de de
répondre c'est plutôt au gouvernement ou
ou ou au représentant au parlementair de
la
majorité que de répondre à notre à à ma
ma ma collègue ça ferait certainement
l'objet là aussi d'une très belle
question au gouvernement je veux pas me
je veux pas me je veux pas me défausser
eu je vais quand même juste vous dire
une chose euh il me semble que c'est
précisément en tenant les debouts avec
toutes les difficulté que ça représente
toutes les toute la complexité qui est
qui est derrière que on est audible
c'est-à-dire en ne versant ni d'un côté
ni de l'autre euh d'une partie ou
l'autre et encore une fois quand je dis
ça je je je sais combien c'est facile à
énoncer et combien c'est difficile à
mettre en
œuvre mais il faut à la fois et je crois
que le Président de la République l'a
fait de même que la ministre de l'Europe
et des Affaires étrangères je je conçois
que ce soit difficile à
entendre il faut à la fois reconnaître
le droit d'Israël à se défendre même
l'obligation vis-à-vis de sa population
à se défendre dans le respect du droit
international humanitaire l'ensemble de
ces mots est important et dit toute la
complexité de la réal de ce qui se passe
h et lorsqu'on derrière cette simple
phrase lorsqu'on entre un peu dans le
détail en effet on a confronté à des
questions redoutables qui
tiennent ce que je disais tout à l'heure
la protection des civils la protection
des personnels humanitaires le le
le le l'accès qui doit être garanti à
ces populations euh de façon à répondre
à à à leur besoin donc c'est c'est
l'ensemble de tout ça qui est qui est
qui est qui est délicat c'est le métier
des diplomates que d'essayer de faire
vivre ensemble des injonctions
contradictoires et c'est je crois le la
la la seule manière pour nous encore une
fois en versant ni d'un côté dans ni
dans l'autre en évitant la caricature en
évitant de céder aussi à la part
d'émotion qui est bien évidemment nous
saisi lorsqu'on voit ce qui se passe
c'est ainsi que euh la France pourra non
seulement faire entendre sa voix mais
être au nombre de au petit nombre des
nations qui pourront euh éclairer ce ce
chemin et et et trouver cette solution
qu'on espère tous depuis très longtemps
déjà merci de cette réponse que je
qualifierai
d'équilibré euh maintenant c'est
Monsieur le Député de
loise député du rassemblement national
Monsieur le Directeur oui ben justement
ma question va englober un petit peu
tout cela euh madame la ministre des
Affaires étrangères évoqué ce jour lors
des questions gouvernement la tenue
d'une conférence dans le but d'aboutir à
une trêve voire un cesser le feu durable
en contradiction avec le souhait
précédemment évoqué d'un droit à se
défendre de la part d'Israël les
ambassadeurs affirment que notre
position en faveur d'Israël au début de
la crise est incomprise au Moyen-Orient
et qu'elle est en rupture avec notre
position traditionnellement et équilibré
entre Israël et et et et la Palestine le
président de la République souhaite
condamner les actes du terrorisme
islamique en Israël sans froisser bien
sûr la population musulmane en France
française ou étrangère de fait son
propos entraîne des réactions à
l'international le conduisant à
s'écarter de la ligne que l'on
connaissait bien de ses parten de ses
partenaires et de sur le conflit voire à
devoir s'excuser de ses propos auprès de
Monsieur Herzog le président euh
israélien Monsieur le Directeur ma
question est est simple vous y avez en
partie répondu au corps des précédentes
interrogations pendant que les annonces
fusent et se contredisent quelle ligne
euh suit sur le terrain l'action du
centre de crise et de soutien du du
ministère des Affaires étrangères euh
que vous représentez ce soir merci
Monsieur le Directeur voyez monsieur le
Monsieur le Directeur Monsieur Guignot
qui est un parlementaire tout à fait
[Musique]
expérimenté conscient il é a reçu votre
réponse et bien il l'a trouvé tellement
satisfaisante qu'il veut que vous la
répétiez mais c'est permettez de cette
fin de soirée de vous
de taquiner un peu Monsieur le
Directeur je vais vous péter ma réponse
mais en essayant pour ne pas trop vous
ennuyer d'en varier les
termes ça c'est du
luxe eu en fait votre la réponse à votre
question est assez facile si on regarde
euh ce ce sujet d'une extrême complexité
d'autres au moins ont qualifié l'Orient
compliqué
euh si on regarde cette cette crise du
strict point de vue du Centre de Crise
euh je vous disais en en introduction
que
je je ne dirige pas un centre qui qui
élabore la doctrine ou qui ou qui édicte
des principe je dirige un un une
équipe très opérationnelle qui a des
missions qui sont très précisément
définis et qui s'attache à les remplir
avec le maximum de rapidité d'efficacité
disponibilité et encore une fois mon
sujet moi c'est j'ai une communauté
française qui est menacée
comment je fais pour au plus vite la
mettre en
sécurité j'ai une population qui a des
besoins humanitaires manifestes dans tel
et tel secteur dans tel et tel
géographie comme on dit aujourd'hui dans
tel et tel pays comment est-ce que je
fais pour apporter cette aide au plus
près au plus vite au mieux si vous
raisonnez comme ça la vie est en fait
beaucoup plus
simple il se trouve qu'elle est un peu
compliqué aussi et là je reviens sur ce
que
je répondait à Madame Soudet à
l'instant jeis vous répondre de vous
faire plusieurs remarques vous faisiez
allusion à à une polémique naissante
aujourd'hui liée à une note rédigée par
les ambassadeurs de France qui aurait
fuité dans la presse il se trouve et je
vous le dis en toute honnêteté que je
n'ai pas lu cette note parce que je
n'étais pas destinataire donc je suis
bien normal de la commenter et pas
davantage l'article qui en est tiré est
ce que je ferai ce soir en rentrant chez
moi euh donc je commenterai pas je
laisserai à ces ambassadeurs la
responsabilité de leurs propos euh sur
le fond euh et de la méthode sur la
forme
euh au moins sur la méthode je pense que
il y a des sujets qu'on gagne à ne pas
traiter sur la place publique je m'en
tiendrai là euh pour ce qui concerne la
ligne qui est la ligne définie par nos
autorités sur ce sujet en particulier et
et là je je je je vous répète ce que je
vous disais à l'instant je crois
précisément que eu si on veut être
efficace si on veut être entendu si l'on
veut euh participer à la réflexion
collective sur la sortie de crise parce
qu'il faudra bien en sortir et donc à la
définition d'une solution qui soit euh
vivable c'est-à-dire qui puisse
satisfaire les légitimes attentes d'une
partie et de l'autre et d'Israël et de
la Palestine si on veut remplir tous ces
critères il faut précisément et je sais
j'en mesure la difficulté c'est mon
travail de tous les jours il faut
précisément que nous
tenions cette position équilibrée le
inmé stattous pour faire
cuistre je suis centriste je ne peux pas
m'insurger contre ce type de propos ça
me va assez bien comme définition de la
politique étrangère de la France centr
triste euh ce que je veux dire par là
c'est que nous serions immédiatement
disqualifiés à tomber d'un côté ou de
l'autre à tenir à des propos qui nous
marquerait d'un côté ou de l'autre et
encore une fois je mesure la difficulté
de de de de ces positions là je crois
que c'est le président de la République
qui un jour avait défini ce qui faisait
la caractéristique de la politique
étrangère française ce qu'il entendait
en tous les cas le tour qu'il entendait
lui donner il avait qualifié de
puissance la France de puissance
d'équilibre je crois qu'il n'y a pas de
plus de plus d'occasion vous savez qu'il
y avait une grande Monsieur le
Directeur permet qu'il y avait une
grande polémique une grande discussion
sur la question de savoir si équilibre
était avec un S ou sans s tout à fait
tout à fait
eu d'ailleurs on pourrait dire que c'est
la puissance
deséquilibre ou oui euh parce que c'est
une c'est une position je pense que qui
qui a qui qui qui qui vaut dans dans
dans beaucoup de de zones dans beaucoup
de de géographie dans beaucoup de de de
de régions aujourd'hui en en en conflit
euh le Président bourlan je rappelle que
je venais de passer 4 ans à Dakar donc
en Afrique de l'Ouest dans une région
qui est secouée de de coup d'État de de
troubles en en tout genre c'est une
autre zone où il est à la fois
extrêmement difficile et extrêmement
nécessaire euh en mesurant bien et la
difficulté et les coups qu'on prend
d'être cette puissance
d'équilibre
merci nous nous avons le monsieur Lecoq
qui a rempli son devoir j'estime je
pense en séance publique et
qui nous fait le plaisir de revenir et
donc il était inscrit au titre de la
Gauche démocrate et républicaine et j'ai
grand plaisir à à lui à lui donner la
parole monsieur Lecoq est vice-président
de cette commission et député de scène
maritime pour être plus précis député du
Havre bonjour Monsieur l'Ambassadeur et
et merci d'avoir répondu à à
l'invitation de la commission moi
d'abord je suis comme mes collègues je
voudrais féliciter les équipes du du
centre de crise que j'ai eu l'occasion
de visiter et que j'ai vu à l'œuvre dans
dans de multiples crises depuis depuis
que je crois le ministre couchner a créé
ce ce centre de crise et et
vraiment c'est un des joyaux du Cadoré
cet outil je j'aimerais savoir parce que
j'ai écouté j'ai écouté sur le chemin
même pendant le vote ce que vous disiez
mais j'aimerais savoir quels sont qui
sont vos yeux à Gaza euh parce que parce
qu'à un moment donné on a j'ai écouté
cet après-midi des questions d'actualité
où on a parlé de de milliers de morts à
Gaza et tout et et et des députés enfin
en tout cas un député criit c'est faux
c'est un mensonge c'est faux c'est faux
euh qui est capable de dire un peu la
vérité la presse dit qu'elle ne peut pas
entrer dans Gaza euh et alors il y a le
Centre culturel français que j'avais eu
l'occasion de visiter à l'occasion de de
la visite avec le président de
l'Assemblée nationale mais euh si on a
rapatrié tout le monde ça veut dire
qu'on a entre guillemets plus de acteur
français quoi sur sur place puisqu'ils
sont rapatriés euh et donc qui vous
permet d'avoir des informations ça c'est
la la première question la deuxième
question je m'associe à ce qu'a dit mon
mon collègue logal sur sur les
personnels de l'ONU est-ce que dans les
dans des ONG des des personnels français
ou proches ou européens ont subi le le
même sort
euh de d'y laisser des vies dans le
casadre du du soutien et avec en AC son
des populations et puis enfin parce que
moi je suis euh j'ai j'ai hésité à
intervenir en fait parce que je depuis
des semaines j'ai je ne sais pas trouver
les bons mots qui qui permettent à mon
cœur de parler et et sans que sans que
ce soit caricaturé et que je sois accusé
de tous les crimes et et et en même
temps je je me dis aujourd'hui quand je
vois le contexte vous avez parlé de de
deux états vous y croyez vraiment moi j
j'y ai cru avant le 7 octobre j'y
croyais encore et quand je vois comment
ça se passe je me dis y a-t-il
réellement une solution
politique question centrale oui de
l'orateur
final merci monsieur le député comme je
l'ai déjà dit je vais transmettre à
l'équipe vos mots je vais les je vais
les transmettre mot à mot et je pense
que ça leur fera énormément plaisir euh
parce qu'il se dévouent sans compter
pour pour ne rien vous cacher je suis
plus tout à fait un perdreau de l'année
quand même hein ça fait 27 ans que je
fais ce métier euh j'ai rarement m vu si
sinon jamais vu une équipe aussi dévouée
c'està-dire moi je le le soir à 22h ou
23h je fais le tour des bureaux pour les
sortir de leur bureau quoi et dire qu'il
faut qu'il rentre chez eux qu'il se
repousse qu'il donc et c'est très euh
euh un moment où parfois on a tendance à
à ici on y arrive pas on les garde à 2h
du matin
euh
ou il a un moment où parfois on peut
douter de de de de de de l'attachement
que qu'on peut avoir un intérêt général
un intérêt collectif des grandes causes
comme celle-là je trouve que c'est
plutôt rassurant d'avoir et des jeunes
en particulier moi j'ai beaucoup de
jeunes dans mes rangs des jeunes qui ont
entre 25 et 30 ans et qui qui passent
non seulement leur journée mais leur
nuit dans leur bureau pour essayer de
pour essayer de d'aider les autres pour
dire les choses de manière de manière
simple
euh deux sujets que vous avez abordé
quels sont vos yeux c'est une excellente
question c'est une question qu'on se
pose tous les jours sur le la fiabilité
d'information qu'on qu'on reçoit et en
fait on croise beaucoup des informations
qui nous qui nous remonte via les
agences des nations- Unies qui sont
encore sur place il faut écouter je l'ai
déjà dit je le répète ce que dit Philipp
Lazarini son équipe de ce qui se passe
sur place parce que ils sont sur place
lui il est rentré dans Gaza à deux
reprises déjà donc il a vu ce qui se
passait et j'invite à réécouter son
intervention en ouverture de la
conférence du ne parce que je pense que
tout il est résumé dans des mots très
simples il a parlé 5 minutes mais ça dit
je crois bien quelle est la situation
sur place donc les agences des Nations
Unis les ONG certaines sont encore
présentes sur place je vais pas toutes
les citer mais je pense à ce qu'a dit
aussi la présidente de MSF là aussi le 9
matin j'avais eu le privilège de de
parler à MS dans une réunion que
qu'avait tenu le directeur de cabinet de
Catherine Colona la veille avec un
certain nombre des grandes ONG
françaises dont
MSF Médecin du Monde actaed première
urgence internationale solidarité
internationale et
d'autres et donc elles nous disent des
choses aussi et et je je leur fais
confiance dans les dans les informations
qu'ell nous donnent nous avons notre
consulat général à Jérusalem de manière
générale le réseau diplomatique et
consulaire
qui a gardé sur place des contacts quand
je dis que l'ensemble des Français ont
été rapatriés l'ensemble des Français
qui souhaitaent être rapatriés ont été
rapatriés certains n'ont pas souhaité
partir et en dehors même des Français
nous avons tout le réseau des des
Palestiniens proches de la France avec
lequel nous continuons d'entretenir des
relations très étroites qui sont des
relations de confiance donc quels sont
nos yeux ce sont ceux-là et je je pense
qu'on a une vision assez juste de ce qui
se passe
et de l'évolution de la situation je
vous garantis pas que elle est exacte à
la minute près mais mais on sait on sait
ce qui se passe sur place ça c'était la
première catégorie de remarques que je
que je voulais faire ave tout ça dit
avec beaucoup d'humilité que le recul
nécessaire je prétends pas avoir la
vérité de ce qui se passe en revanche
j'essaie de croiser pour éclairer la
décision de de ceux qui doivent la
prendre à commencer par la ministre
d'affaires étrangères et le président de
la République ça c'est la première série
de remarqu deuxième série de remarques
très très importante la question que
vous posez là aussi sur est-ce qu'il
faut encore croire aux deux
états je je je vais vous dire deux
choses la première c'est que je connais
pas d'autres solution que celle-là euh
et que donc si elle est
extraordinairement difficile et si les
événements récents ne la facilite pas je
ne connais pas d'autres solutions
aujourd'hui qui soi de nature à assurer
sécurité dans la durée et d'Israël et de
la Palestine j' nen connais pas d'autres
je je et je suis pas le seul et on est
on est nombreux à essayer de de de
d'imaginer d'inventer autre chose et
personne n est encore arrivé encore à ma
connaissance celui où celle qui arrivera
sera prix Nobel de la paix je pense il
aura largement mérité je juste vous dire
une dernière chose pour pour qu'on se
quitte pas sur un mot de de désespoir
même si aujourd'hui tout nous y
porte on a connu d'autres cas dans
l'histoire et dans d'autres pays du
monde d'État qui se détestaient jusqu'au
point de s'être entre dééchiré jusqu'au
très fond d'eux-mêm et de leur
population et qui ont trouvé non
seulement le ressort avec les hommes
d'État et femmes d'État qui étaient
nécessair à l'époque qui ont trouvé le
ressort pour passer pardà leur
différence et bâtir des relations qui
sont parmi aujourd'hui les plus solides
et les plus fécondes vous voyez à quoi
je fais référence c'est ce que je
souhaite à cette région du Levant
oui je vous remercie ce que vous dites
me touche beaucoup parce que c'est
là-dessus que j'avais conclu
l'intervention que j'avais faite à
l'Assemblée nationale dans les jours qui
ont suivi et j'avais effectivement parlé
du logiciel européen en disant que ce
qui caractérisait ce qui caractérisait
les solutions européennes je sais que il
y a chos qui ne marche je pas c'était
l'idée qu'on ne
pouvait défendre sa propre situation
assurer sa sécurité assurer sa
prospérité assurer sa sérénité qu'à la
condition de prendre en compte la
stabilité la sécurité la sérénité de
celui d'en face que nous avions
vis-à-vis de l'Allemagne pendant des
siècles pas si longtemps que ça enfin
disons depuis de Philippe de de Frédéric
II à à Hitler n nous nous sommes
vraiment battu très très sévèrement très
très sévèrement et sans aucun succès en
terme de sécurité nous avons toujours
mais moi j'ai mes deux mes deux
grands-parents étaient officiel Activ et
engagé pendant la guerre de 14 euh ça a
toujours été et leurs parents et ma
maison a été détruite à dunkererque en
en mai 40 et cetera nous avons tous vécu
ça et ça s'est arrêté je veux dire que
on peut peut-être avoir des discussions
un peu pénibles avec les Allemands sur
le prix de l'énergie mais on est
absolument en sécurité dans notre
relation avec Échavé et je crois que ce
logiciel là c'est ça qui a manqué au
gouvernement israélien ces dernières
années c'est de prendre en compte l'idée
que la stabilité et la sécurité
d'israëlle passer par la prise en compte
des intérêts légitimes de la partie d'en
face je crois que c'est
alors la question que pose si vous me
permettez oui non non alors si vous me
permettez d'ajouter une chose sur les
deux états dans dans mon intervention
j'avais une formule un peu digne de
monterland j'avais dit il est à la fois
trop tôt et trop tard pour faire les
deux états trop trop tard c'est évident
parce que on a eu euh
l'histoire nous a nous a servi les plats
au au
moment
avec avec Isaac Rabine nous avons eu les
accords d'Oslo nous avons eu une
possibilité et nous l'avons laissé
échapper et maintenant il est évident je
crois que le monsieur Lecoq a raison de
le dire que c'est effroyable d'imaginer
qu'on construise deux états encore que
deux États qui soissent peuvent
coexister comme on le voit en en Corée
par exemple mais euh c'est c'est
évidemment inimaginable de construire
deux états on va se retrousser les
manches et demain matin on va faire deux
états sur la base de ces ces immenses
destruction que nous observons en
revanche je crois qu'il y a quantité que
c'est comme la l'a dit euh monsieur
Lalot c'est c'est la seule solution qui
existe et qu'il y a des gestes à affire
qui permettront demain d'y conduire
c'est vrai que si on arrêtait et si on
faisait refluer euh la colonisation en
6jordanie je pense que ce serait un
signe extrêmement fort si on arriver à
trouver une une une réorganisation d'une
OLP respectable
euh avec une autorité un peu forte je
n'ai rien contre le président mahamouas
enfin c'est un vieil homme qui n'a pas
beaucoup d'autorité aujourd'hui mais si
on reconstituait l'unité de l'Autorité
palestinienne on aurait un un
interlocuteur la communauté
internationale a commencé par l'Union
européenne se se mais très certainement
ferait un certain nombre d'efforts pour
reconstruire quelque chose donc je crois
qu'à terme ça n'est pas ça n'est pas
impossible parce que l'autre solution
l'autre solution et c'est ça qui
m'inquiète parce que je sens que non pas
le le peuple israélien dans son ensemble
mais que le le gouvernement israélien
actuel la la caresse c'est l'idée de la
solution par le vide on on prend 2
millions de 2 millions de gaz de de de
gens à Gaza et on les expédie du côté du
maréchal ci qui évidemment n'en veut pas
donc ça marche pas on rend par des
bombardements systéma absolument
invivable cette zone et puis de l'autre
côté on organise d'une façon extrêmement
préoccupante la précarité pour ne pas
dire la vulnérabilité des
populations des populations en
sisjordanie avec l'idée que ils seront
très bien chez le roi
Abdallah ça c'est la solution par le
vide et c'est une solution
chimérique non seulement c'est une
solution inhumaine mais c'est une une
solution chimérique donc quand vous
enlevez celle-là qu'est-ce qui vous
reste bah il vous reste l'idée de
construire deux entités et de prendre le
temps pour le faire mais il faut
commencer par inverser les signes moi on
on parle beaucoup de trêve humanitaire
de cesser le feu moi je je veux dire le
le le cesser le feu je comprends très
bien mais le vrai problème que me pose
depuis le début depuis le début depuis
le premier jour depuis le le 8 le 8
octobre la l'attitude du prés Premier
ministre israélien gouvernement
israélien c'est que je ne vois pas leur
schéma je ne vois pas leur
option c'est une option militaire
inexistante que l'option qu'ils ont
choisi c'est kusvitz le montre très bien
kusv la guerre la guerre c'est une
espèce de mouvement ascensionnel ce
qu'il appelle l'ascension aux extrêmes
qu'on appelle l'escalade qui va vers la
guerre totale
ce qu'il appelle la guerre absolue sauf
quand il y a des considérations
politiques qui sont qu'est-ce que ça me
rapporte qu'est-ce que ça me coûte et
donc quel quel est mon objectif
politique qui maintienne ce que Klaus VZ
appelle la guerre réelle à un niveau
inférieur à la guerre absolue moi je
cluswi c'est un auteur formidable je je
partage l'amour de clus Vitz avec lénin
Etap mais
c'est c'était mais et là donc quel est
l'objectif politique et c'est ça qu'on
ne comprend pas dans la la la situation
quel est vers quel évidemment la la la
forme de la guerre et est conditionnée
par le but de la guerre par le but
politique de la guerre or là je ne vois
pas à part on a eu AP pllatir le Liban
on a eu il restera rien de Gaza et
cetera tout ça ce sont moi je comprends
la légitime défense hein je veux dire
que ceux qui s'est passé le 7 la la la
la violence insensée insensée mise en
scène
terrifiante qui a été ne pouvait ne peut
pas ne pas entraîner une volonté de de
de de de réaction mais quelle était
l'attitude moi je crois qu'il y avait
d'abord la question des otages qui
devait être je sais qu'Israël c'est
beaucoup préoccupé des otages et a
consenti des des marchés incroyables un
un un un pales
contre 1000 palestiniens contre un
Israélien enfin des choses comme ça donc
les otages il y avait aussi peut-être
l'idée de détruire
intelligemment ce qui est
hamass après tout à Munich à Munich vous
vous rappelez Munich à Munich les
Israéliens ont une réaction précise ils
ont dit tous ceux qui ont participé au
commando disparaîtront et ils l'ont fait
ils les ont tous tués mais c'est une
réponse proportionnée c'était une
réponse adaptée à la violence de de
l'attentat de Munich à l'horreur de de
ce qui s'est passé à ce moment-là mais
c'était très limité là moi je je
j'aurais compris qu'on dise
bah voilà il y a 1500 personnes on a les
noms et et et cela on s'en occupera dans
les de TR années qui viennent c'était
une je donne ça comme exemple une
réponse une réponse militaire possible
mais là qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce qu'on
fait exactement vers quoi vers quelle
solution débouche cette guerre c'est ça
que je ne vois pas alors le CESS le feu
évidemment cess le feu naniahou nous dit
ah bah vous voulez dédoiner à masse ce
qu'il a fait c'est inacceptable mais la
la guerre qu'il a choisi est une guerre
qui me paraît pas avoir un un un
objectif clairement clairement identifié
en tout cas un objectif compatible avec
ce que la communauté internationale a
commencé par par nous nous défendons
quand nous préconisons la solution des
deux états avec et et cette réponse
contribue à à à nourrir le le
scepticisme de notre collègue et que je
comprends parfaitement donc je je trouve
que c'est ça qui est très très troublant
moi ça c'est Monsieur Lecoq a dit qu'il
avait du mal à
s'exprimer moi aussi moi j'ai fait ce ce
discours très vite à à l'Assemblée
nationale et je suis très silencieux
depuis parce que je ne j'ai du mal à à à
voir ce qu'on peut opposer
à à une politique à une une orientation
qui est celle du gouvernement israélien
qui me paraît très très profondément
mauvaise mais qui qui qui est seule qui
qui est seule sur la table et qui
aboutit à des désastres vous savez moi
j'ai j'ai j'ai un exemple
que je cite toujours je l'avais cité
l'ambassadeur d'Algérie qui évidemment a
bondi là-dessus en parlant de
colonialisme mais c'est les les
attentats de
Philippeville ce qui s'est passé à
Philippeville
en en août si je me rappelle bien en
août
55 les les braves Français d'Algérie qui
était là sont partis travailler le matin
et sont revenus le soir il y avait eu
des des commandos du FLN qui avait tué
tout le monde qui avait tué à peu près
100 100 150 personnes dans des
conditions atroocce comparable à ce
qu'on a vu le 7 7 octobre en Israël les
enfants les femmes enceintes tout ça
était qu'est-ce qui s'est passé
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé les les
soulevé par une colère qu'on comprend
très bien les les pinoirs se sont
regroupés et ils ont tué pendant
plusieurs jours je crois à peu près près
5000 arabes dans la ville de philipville
c'est de ce moment que la guerre
d'Algérie a cessé d'être le combat de
quelques militants flln derrière Ben
Bella qui avait fait l'attentat de
Novembre 54 pour devenir l'affaire de
tout un peuple et c'est c'est cet
enchaînement là qui est terrifiant et
c'est ça qu'il faut absolument arrêter
me semble-t-il c'est ce type
d'enchaînement où c'est atroce les sans
morts mais la réaction était était
effectivement disproportionnée et mot
disproportionné est toujours un peu
obscène quand on parle on compare à 100
morts mais était disproportionné et
surtout à a conduit très très clairement
à des résultats exactement opposés à
ceux que poursuivaient ceux qui se sont
livrés à cela et je ressens
personnellement je vous le dis on
termine cette réunion entre entre nous
nous ne nous ne nous ne faisons pas de
de communiquer les gens peuvent nous
écouter mais c'est tout à fait normal
que nous ayons ce type de réflexion mais
je je pense que c'est moi en tout cas
comme Monsieur leco dit je suis je suis
je suis mué parce que je ne sais pas
exactement ce qu'il faut dire à un
moment précis moi ce que je ressens
c'est cette escalade là le risque que ça
représente et l'éloignement que ça
comporte par rapport à la seule solution
qui soit qui soit légitime deux états
appelons
ça de permettant à deux communautés
humaines la communauté palestinienne et
la communauté israélienne de vivre
sereinement de vivre en sécurité alors
appelons ça deux états appelons ça comme
on veut mais c'est ça le seul objectif
que nous devons poursuivre et je pense
que derrière tout ça l'Ascension
est menace dans quelques jours d'ailles
c'est ce que disent un peu les
Israéliens ils disent on peut encore
faire du dégât pendant 15 jours et puis
après ça sera on aura tout le monde
contre nous mais regardez le le les ce
qui se passe au Liban
le le le le chef du hzbollah a fait un
discours extrêmement tile à sa manière
et cetera il y a 8 jours montrant bien
que il avait pas envie de s'engager trop
manifestement très tenu en main par ses
maîtres iraniens mais malgré tout
regardez la multiplication des incidents
en ce moment à à la frontière il y a
beaucoup plus de de il y a beaucoup plus
de fusées qui partent de de elles vont
un peu plus loin tout ça n'est pas du
tout stabilisé et et et et et et la rue
arabe comme on dit enfin les les les les
les états moi quand je discute avec vos
vos collègues mon cher directeur ils
sont très préoccupés par le caractère
volatile de la situation dans tout le
monde dans tout le monde musulman dans
tout le monde arabe donc nous sommes
vraiment est-ce que nous en sommes nous
nous disons c'est c'est le feu B c'est
c'est le feu c'est c'est beaucoup plus
profond il faut évidemment que nous
réenclenchions un système et je crois
que le alors là je parle en mon nom
personnel et ni au nom de la majorité ni
au nom de personne et certainement pas
au nom de de l'administration mais je
crois que le
discours le discours de la France
devrait être plus plus net plus clair
plus dans dans ce sens et que il y a eu
des entre le discours sur la cesse et le
feu puis le coup de téléphone au
président d'Israël tout tout cela donne
une image un petit peu difficile à
interpréter or nous devons nous Français
et nous nous Européens et nous Français
nous l'avons toujours fait en Europe ça
a toujours été nous qui avons marqué le
le le le départ nous devons
effectivement à mon avis faire tout ce
qui est en notre pouvoir pour
redonner légitimité et crédibilité à
cette à cette solution à terme des deux
états enfin à cette solution
d'apaisement entre les communautés
palestiniennes et israéliennes d'où
pourra peut-être un jour sortir les deux
états je dis ça avec prudence mais je
crois que c'est ce devoir là bah ça ça
permettrait si on le faisait bien de
rendre un peu de sérénité à Monsieur
Lecoq ça serait déjà
ça je voilà ce que je je me permets de
vous dire à titre tout à fait personnel
mais nous vivons tous je vous connais
bien les uns et les autres nous vivons
tous ce drame avec nos nous n'avons pas
les mêmes les mêmes présupposés nous
n'avons pas les les les les mêmes
mais les mêmes orientations politiques
mais je crois que nous vivons tous ce
drame avec une conscience aigue de
l'extrême gravité de la situation alors
voilà voilà ce que je voulais comme on a
on a eu un peu plus de temps que prévu
je me suis permis de de faire écho à à
la
l'observation qui m'a paru très très
très légitime et très pertinente de
notre vice-président euh car je crois
qu'en fait on partage tous un peu ce
même ce ce ce ce même constat et ça me
permet je sais pas si vous voulez
ajouter quelque chose mais ça me permet
en tout cas de conclure en vous
remerciant infiniment Monsieur le
Directeur j' j'avais eu de des relations
très très très fructueuses de travail
avec vous quand j'étais allé au Sénégal
là vous nous avez donné un un éclairage
extrêmement précis sur les efforts de la
France sur l'organisation de ce centre
vous avez vu et le fait que vous soyez
notre invité ce
soir quelques mois seulement après que
votre prédécesseur l'IT été sur
l'affaire du Soudan et vous avez entendu
par les parole de chacun donc celle
d'ailleurs de notre vice-président que
nous nous sommes extrêmement fiers que
la France est mise au point cet
instrument administratif et nous sommes
extrêmement reconnaissants à tous les
fonctionnaires qui servent euh sous
votre autorité et qui jouent un rôle
extrêmement précieux euh car comme vous
l'avez dit vous tenez un peu les deux
bouts de la chaîne entre la protection
consulaire et l'action humanitaire et le
et l'anticipation des des moyens vous
vous avez euh une approche qui est
extrêmement positive donc vraiment merci
d'être venu ce soir merci de ce que vous
faites et félicitations au personnel qui
sous votre autorité servent assurent le
service public dans des conditions
particulièrement particulièrement
admirable Monsieur David vous voulez
dire quelque chose parler après vous
Président vous avez conclu c'est c'est
juste lors de de la covid on avait un
contact on avait comment dire un relais
auprès de votre de votre structure euh
depuis ça s'est un peu étiolé on s'est
on s'est écarté un peu est-ce qu'on
pourrait remettre en place est-ce qu'on
pourrait remettre en place ce système
qui était un système parfait entre
Monsieur L et moi les relations sont
sont
sont assz transparent mais on va faire
ça répondez répondz à Monsieur David
coupe coupe tonur du ministre c'était le
collaborateur c'était pas à l'intérieur
du centre de crise c'était le
collaborateur parlementaire du ministre
qui faisait la qui faisait l'interface
membre de la
C m de la bon allez on va pas on va
laisser monsieur Lalot nous dire ce
qu'il ce qu'il pense de ce de la
l'instit la réinstitution d'un contact
un peu structurel ce qui serait
effectivement très très très bienvenu
chez nous je je j'ajoute une dernière
chose non non je
suis nous sommes à votre disposition
bien évidemment moi le premier et je dis
pas je dis pas ça en l'air
eu merci encore une fois pour pour tous
ces pour tous ces mots que je vais
transmettre qui me font rosir de plaisir
et qui font certainement rosir de
plaisir l'une des
brillantes collaboratrices du centre de
Christ qui qui m'accompagne ce soir et
qui est bien à l'image de ce centre vous
voyez à quel point elles sont jeunes
talentueuses brillantes et et impliqué
merci beaucoup en tous les cas voilà
merci euh la séance estlevée